so okay so you grew up in Merced yep
we have very so I was watching you talk
about your family situation and I feel
like we have very similar
human beings around us as we were
growing up yeah where'd you grow up I
grew up in Phoenix
oh God you're just looking at me a
terrible area of Arizona I grew up in an
area called Sunny Slope which was like
Hell's Angels ran it was [__] I like
the central belly it was like it was
like Mexicans and Hell's Angels ran my
area and all my [__] family members
were [__] fiend out you know what I'm
saying shout out to my mom she wasn't
but my dad had his little issues with
crack for a little bit you know what I'm
saying
um my uncles were all Tweakers all my
cousins are in and out of prison and it
was funny because I related to your
story about for people who don't know
you're
mom ended up with a
person who went to prison and came out
as like a white supremacist he survived
oh no he was there he was already oh he
was already there oh yeah when I met him
I was like Mom is this the guy you're
dating right he's gonna get a shot well
it's crazy because I have a cousin named
Aaron God rested so he passed away in
prison maybe like seven years ago but
him and my cousin Sheldon Sheldon is
still alive in prison right now but he's
Mexican Mafia so in Arizona it's like
Mexican Mafia right in an Aryan Nation
in prison yeah but these two guys are
the same age so they grew up causing
hell together
in Phoenix and then they ended up both
in the system but they ended up both in
the system on opposites opposite sides
right so nobody ever knew they were
related so my cousin Aaron gets out of
PR because my cousin Sheldon looks like
a [__] cholo like his whole entire
body's tattooed uh he's [__] you
would never know he's half white ever my
cousin Aaron he was running the white
side in prison
when he got out of prison for like a cup
of coffee and I took him to a Busta
Rhymes concert
and he [__] because he loved hip-hop
but he couldn't love hip-hop yeah 100 so
we got his [__] Busta Rhymes concert
and he was just having the time of his
[__] life like knows all the lyrics
and I'm like what and I had to like when
we went
had to wear his whole I was like oh come
on yeah cover that [__] up yeah because
he had all the tattoos and share but I
related to that because you had said
that you're
your stepdad was not necessarily racist
only racist and he explained it to me
because my best friend was black yeah
and his dad was the big you ever watch
UFC yeah remember Marvin beastman
Eastman the little short dude yeah his
older brother is my best friend's dad
and he's six four
built like the Rock and there's my
stepdad built like Edward Norton in
America I mean he was a monster
but he explained it to me because I
remember I brought him over one day and
in my head of thought
are you is this gonna be okay I never
got that vibe from him but I remember
thinking thinking about that he told me
when he left he goes I don't know if you
know like I love him that's like my kid
it's your best friend I gotta act like
that in jail so I can come back home he
didn't explain everything to me until I
was about 13. my mom and him got
divorced and then
we went like a a tweaker camping trip
which is just laying in the in the in
the field next to the trailers and like
he dug a hole in the side of the
mountain so we could sit like in a couch
he's like that's what I used to do I
didn't have a house and all this is
crazy [__] tell me I throw knives that
weekend
and uh
it's just weird man it's weird because I
always think I just because I just
brought him up I haven't seen him in 12
years yeah and I just saw him on a
arrest report
and wow like he looks like those monster
Tweakers in jail oh yeah no teeth yeah
strung out yeah I got a few of them that
was in my family yeah that was my kind
of like my dad for eight years plus
right yeah my dad was on drugs and never
cared so
like here's my stepdad everybody's like
he's a bad guy I'm like
in certain places he is yes he's fully
covered except uh stops here stops here
and stops here how egregious are the
tattoos though are they lightning bolts
are they swastikas bolts swastikas oh
he's got the whole [__] Lightnings
all over his head
uh White is right was hella big on his
body and I always ask him like what is
that the first time I asked him like
what is that
and then he explained like what racism
is in prison yeah yeah he was like he
had to give you that like breakdown of
like I had to survive my sister's Brown
as [__] well in in Cali I think the
Mexicans and the whites are kind of
affluent Spanish and [__] he told me a
lot about it I mean I can't obviously
talk about what he talked to me about
but he's down with them yeah he's down I
spoke flu in Spanish
taught me some [__] which is the
funniest thing I've ever said to people
I told that to Dr Drew and that's when I
realized like wait that is stupid
why supremacist taught me Spanish
because you don't speak Spanish Flu all
right yeah the whole family sucks they
never taught me [__] that's funny but
they make fun of me for not speaking it
but they never taught me so it's like
you didn't [__] teach me bro
come on it's not my fault it's my mom's
uh have to shoot my grandma's Jewish and
my other grandma's my grandpa was from
is uh from Texas and Mexican right so
like half my family's white Jewish
people other half my family's Mexican as
hell
and uh I don't speak Spanish so they're
real like white boy I'm like you check
some boxes for sure and I was this color
till I was like 12. and then I don't
know what happened one summer at
football I just turned brown you just
filled out yeah it was a trip dude